megan the stallion getting candid about
that shooting incident last month
sharing some graphic pics and let me
tell you
it's not pretty the 25 year old rapper
took to instagram wednesday to clap back
at the haters who seem
to believe she made the whole story up
in the since-deleted post
meg shared these two close-up shots of
her feet that
appear to have been taken shortly after
the incident
the wap wrapper had to undergo surgery
to remove the bullet
fragments ouch and if that weren't
enough to drop the mic
on her haters she captioned the pics
quote
what i have learned about majority of
the people on social media
is y'all like to hear bad news before
good news
a lie spreads quicker than the truth and
y'all really be believing the sh
y'all make up megan wrapped up her post
writing
god was really watching over me and i'm
healing so well
in july megan opened up about the
shooting in an instagram live q a
oh no i think i was gonna cry
but yeah i had to get surgery it was
super scary it was like
just the worst experience of my life
there's nothing to joke about
it was nothing for y'all to start going
and making up
fake stories about
i didn't put my hands on nobody
i didn't deserve to get shot and do like
she also shared details about the
injuries she sustained
and thank god that the bullets didn't
touch bones
they didn't break tendons like i know i
know my mama my daddy
my granny had to be looking out for me
with that one and before her emotional
live
meg spoke briefly about the shooting on
twitter
and called out the people who were
making jokes about it writing in
part quote it might be funny to y'all on
the internet and just another messy
topic for you to talk about
but this is my real life and i'm real
life hurt
and traumatized you're gonna try to feel
like your space with a bunch of people
that you think is making you happy
[Music]
girls